Игорь А.: Да, отлично. Тогда начнем со знакомства. Значит, мне интересно, с кем вы в основном работаете сейчас? Родители, дети, может быть, еще какие -то семьи? То есть кто ваш сейчас клиент?
Игорь А.: Или какие -то, может быть, несколько портретов клиентов?
Ирина Т.: Вообще я работаю с семейными системами Я системный терапевт, семейный системный терапевт И работаю в целом с системой Даже если приходит один человек Я все равно рассматриваю, как оно
Ирина Т.: влияет друг на друга По каким законам это все рассмотреть можно Чтобы понять, что происходит, видно, в чем дисфункция Поэтому, когда приходят с детьми, естественно, первым делом я работаю
Ирина Т.: с родителями То есть понимаем, что ребенок это все -таки такой симптом до семейной системы если в ней есть дисфункция то соответственно в ребенке это все и будет фоне для того чтобы
Ирина Т.: система либо развилась как -то либо соответственно не развалилась поэтому все вот эти вот задачи когда мне приводит детей говорят что поправьте его вот что -то с ним не так я сейчас
Ирина Т.: начинаю первую очередь изучать семейный контекст вот поэтому просто отдельно с детьми не имея связи с родителями я не работаю лет до 18 наверное остальное все идет в таком комплексе
Ирина Т.: когда я либо либо с мамой, либо с папой, либо с двумя вместе, и отдельно идет работа с ребенком. По ребенку я даю обратную связь с родителем в голосовых сообщениях, либо это такие же
Ирина Т.: параллельные занятия. Вот если брать там, как у Максима, да, а не вне этой программы, то в основном здесь занятия параллельные идут родители и дети, если только ребенок не против. Такое
Ирина Т.: бывает, что ребенок против, говорит, ну ничего не рассказываете пока. Хорошо, тогда так. А так вот даже обратную связь бывает не даю. сейчас с Дианой работаю, она не разрешает обратно
Ирина Т.: в связь с родителем, ну что делать? Родители не
Игорь А.: против, если бы были против, я бы не
Ирина Т.: согласилась, естественно, работать.
Ирина Т.: Что еще сказать? У меня достаточно немалое количество таких курсов, групповых программ, вебинаров,
Игорь А.: семинаров, вот такие штуки
Ирина Т.: я веду по детско -родительским отношениям, про теорию развития, про границы, привязанность, сепарацию, такие штуки, да, какие -то эфиры могу проводить, мелкие, на конкретные задачи.
Ирина Т.: Семинары, вебинары. Вот так вот. С детьми маленького возраста не очень люблю работать. Маленького – это дошкольного. То есть я с ними работаю в групповом формате, индивидуально не очень
Ирина Т.: люблю работать. Это надо очно и, в общем, другая немножко, другая история. А вот начиная лет с 12, если у ребенка есть собственный запрос на какую -то помощь, поддержку или пространство,
Ирина Т.: получается очень даже рабочая история. здорово
Игорь А.: а вот я услышал про медийность про этом открытость такое в целом откуда приходят клиенты то есть какие то вот может быть соцсети рекомендации там ученики или там родители рекомендуют
Игорь А.: друг друга ну вообще
Ирина Т.: у меня конечно больше всего работать сарафанное радио ну то есть она всегда для меня работа лучше чем какие -то прямые продажи просто хорошо работой и что называется да люди к тебе
Ирина Т.: присылают всем кому плохо да и канал детско -родительской психологически неотложка в telegram где там вопросы -ответы какой -то материал контент выкладывают там же все всякие эфирчики
Ирина Т.: еще что -то сейчас перерыв год дела сейчас собираюсь возобновить что еще я веду групповые занятия с детьми воспитание искусством и оттуда конечно приходит большое количество клиентов
Ирина Т.: потому что начинаешь работать с детьми где -то в коридорах что -то переобщался, перемолвился, люди спрашивают, а вы консультируете? Да, консультирую. А вот семинары... Вот вчера велась
Ирина Т.: семинар по формированию границу детей. Было 15 человек. Ну, очень семинары, это сейчас не часто бывает. То есть люди приходят в основном друг от друга. Иногда даже бывает, что сижу,
Ирина Т.: клиентов мало думаю, я даже не понимаю, куда податься. Потому что то, что я, например, в сторис выложила, оно, даже если это сообщение какое -то не прямое, да, приходить на консультацию,
Ирина Т.: не знаю, там, песню спела там или какой -то контент выложила что -то про что -то, да, оно, конечно, дает какой -то отклик, там, один -два человека про меня вспомнили, записались. А
Ирина Т.: вот так вот, чтобы прям потоком я понимала, как мне взять клиентов, если они кончились, у меня такой истории, к сожалению, нет.
Игорь А.: Понятно. Ну, да, это одна из таких базовых задач привлечения, это есть такое у многих. А вот бывает ли такое, что родители приходят не по профильному запросу, то есть, может быть, кроме
Игорь А.: основной услуги, еще какие -то нестандартные вопросы или запросы от них приходят? Если бывает, то какие?
Ирина Т.: Уточняйте, не могу понять вопрос, что такое непрофильный запрос. Профильный запрос – это что, на помощь ребенку, а непрофильный на помощь себе? Нет, ну, например, не в области психологии.
Ирина Т.: Что вы имеете в виду? То есть
Игорь А.: поиск эксперта не в области психологии.
Ирина Т.: А в какой же области? Не знаю, порекомендовать
Игорь А.: кого -то еще, то есть порекомендовать кого -то еще, там, смежного какого -то специалиста, эксперта.
Ирина Т.: Естественно, психиатры, логопеды, нейропсихологи. У меня есть некий круг людей, с которыми я сотрудничаю, урологи, которые присылают мне клиентов, с которыми не могут физически решить
Ирина Т.: вопросы, в голове копаться надо. это есть сюда со взрослыми людьми работаю да то
Игорь А.: есть в принципе рекомендательная ты уже пошел на свой круг общения и экспертов я правильно понимаю что рекомендую что также рекомендую тебя и вот отсюда там сарафанка возникает тоже
Игорь А.: да но в
Ирина Т.: меньшей степени чем клиентов а
Игорь А.: вот если говорить про деньги, то какой чек является нормой для твоих клиентов, то есть что они готовы платить, за какие услуги. Если это нормально сказать, то можешь поделиться, пожалуйста.
Ирина Т.: Я бы сказала, у меня охвачено три слоя, я работаю с ними со всеми. Это сложилось в процессе работы. Есть слой, где 10 тысяч в час – это абсолютно нормальная стоимость, люди не запариваются,
Ирина Т.: прям пишут, да, мне нормально, и все. Ну, то есть у меня такой баннер, на котором этот ценник висит. Взрослые 10 тысяч, дети в постоянной работе 8. Есть люди, которые 8 -6, это, знаете,
Ирина Т.: такой контингент, которым надо, вот им пипец надо. Как бы да, им надо, они готовы на терапию выделить, там, допустим, 10 сессий, они вот отказались от чего -то другого, там, от фитнеса
Ирина Т.: и взяли, ходят в психотерапию. С ними я работаю.
Ирина Т.: Это, как правило, на конкретную задачу. Человек реально пришел решить задачу, мы ее решили, все, он откланялся, спасибо, сказал все и ушел. И есть люди, которым очень нужна помощь,
Ирина Т.: им очень плохо, и они, что называется, я ей по полторы, по три могу провести, но это такая штука из изобилия. Если у меня силы есть и денег достаточно, я это делаю, если нет, то не
Ирина Т.: делаю.
Игорь А.: Хорошо. Хорошо. Вот смотри, я почему задаю эти вопросы. Понятное дело, что буду презентовать нашу партнерскую программу, как мы можем взаимодействовать в этом во всем. Это я забегаю
Игорь А.: немножко наперед. И поэтому такой вопрос задам. Комфортно ли тебе что -то вообще в целом рекомендовать своей аудитории? И где вот эта грань, когда ты чувствуешь, блин, я что -то впариваю,
Игорь А.: или окей, норм? То есть вот где у вас нет внутреннего конфликта?
Ирина Т.: У меня есть внутренний конфликт. Я рекомендую, когда точечно что -то, я во что -то очень верю, например, ведет нейропсихолог, которому доверяю, по СДВГ -вебинар какой -то, и я могу
Ирина Т.: дать ссылку, сказать, что смотрите, там Стас ведет вебинар, присоединяйтесь и все такое. То есть я не буду продавать, но проинформирую людей.
Ирина Т.: С продажами не моя это сильная история. Я могу какой -то свой вебинар продать, семинар. Кого -то продать, ну вот да, наверное, в таком режиме, что если я знаю, что это классный вебинар,
Ирина Т.: или я знаю, что это классный специалист, и понимаю, что человеку именно он нужен сейчас, то да, я пересылаю.
Игорь А.: Я тогда не буду ходить вокруг да около, расскажу тот продукт, о котором я говорю, о вот этой партнерской программе. Как в целом у нас строится вся воронка, как, например, вас подключают
Игорь А.: как экспертов. То есть у нас, по сути, вводный такой продукт, который есть, и мы его сейчас полностью сделали автоматическим, то есть он формируется в нашей системе, это профориентация.
Игорь А.: И как раз таки из -за того, что после профориентации нам нужны эксперты, которых мы привлекаем, мы подумали, что возможно, экспертам интересно будет также эту профориентацию кому -то
Игорь А.: рекомендовать, опять же, если есть внутреннее такое вот, во -первых, понимание пользы, во -вторых, что такое профориентация есть и что она даст пользователю, вернее, клиенту. И я могу
Игорь А.: немножко рассказать о самой профориентации и партнерской программе. И потом, если будет интересно, мы можем диалог этот продолжить, когда у нас этот продукт будет готов. Зачем мы делаем
Игорь А.: сейчас вот с вами созвон, с другими экспертами, чтобы этот продукт как раз -таки сделать хорошим, качественным и с пониманием вот этой пользы, которую, во -первых, вам было не стыдно
Игорь А.: нести, да, и понятно, зачем. С другой стороны, нам тоже сделать классный продукт, который бы вы, как вот вебинар кого -то, просто рекомендовали, но еще и за это получали партнерскую
Игорь А.: премию, так сказать. Вот, ну, если говорить про путь нашего клиента, то он обычно тоже по сарафанному радио часто идет, и семья приходит за тем, чтобы помогли с выбором вуза, либо с
Игорь А.: поступлением в какой -либо вуз. И чтобы понять, в какой вуз, на какую программу, на какие специальности учиться, где потом ребенку, когда он вырастет, работать, мы отматываем немножко
Игорь А.: назад, к первому шагу, и начинаем с профориентации. У нас собственная методика, в ней, да, есть международные методологии, заложенные BigFive и Reosec, но мы их переработали и сделали
Игорь А.: свой продукт. Он, по сути, раскладывает на мелкие, так сказать, атомы склонности ребенка, предрасположенности, что нравится, чем классно заниматься, что вдохновляет, что наоборот не
Игорь А.: нравится. То есть мы, по сути, делаем короткий опрос онлайн. Это вот все, цифровой продукт полностью. Онлайн с родителями, то есть какое участие они в воспитании и обучении ребенка
Игорь А.: проходят. Там короткий, буквально он за 5 минут, даже за 3 минуты. Я сам его проходил.
Игорь А.: И со своими дочками тоже профориентацию проходил эту. И далее у ребенка вот эти вот тоже там два более больших теста, они минут 40 занимают, там максимум час. И на основании контекста
Игорь А.: семьи и предрасположенности ребенка как раз -таки у нас появляется большая карта, там страница 40, наверное, этот отчет, куда, условно говоря, ребенок предрасположен с точки зрения
Игорь А.: его навыков, и куда не предрасположен, то есть где будет страдать, если выбрать это направление. Таким образом, мы простраиваем цепочку к вузу, в котором будет, например, специальность
Игорь А.: и курс, который разовьет эти способности, и на какую профессию потом ребенок, когда вырастет и отучится, поступит. То есть мы, получается, первый наш шаг в нашей собственной воронке
Игорь А.: сделали цифровым продуктом, который помогает и ускоряет, во -первых, работу агентства, во -вторых, помогает нам вот этот путь выстроить, потому что раньше, условно говоря, это все было
Игорь А.: вручную, полуавтоматически, с большим количеством касаний с ребенком, с родителями. Сейчас мы это все выносим в платформу, на которой это все будет достаточно быстро делаться. И, соответственно,
Игорь А.: сам продукт, о котором хотел поговорить, это партнерская программа, в которой, например, если к вам обращается клиент, и вы понимаете, что ему это полезно, мы делаем партнерский кабинет.
Игорь А.: Он, скорее всего, на этой неделе будет готов. Что в нем? У вас будет персональная ссылка внутренняя на кабинет, у вас будут лендинги, которые формируются, и, например,
Игорь А.: цена вы можете варьировать. Я почему спросил, вот тоже есть категории, которые готовы, условно говоря, 150 тысяч платить, а есть которые 20. И у нас там минимальная цена заложена программно
Игорь А.: 20 тысяч, рекомендуемая 35 для широкой аудитории, но есть и 100, и 150. Ну, в общем, потолок мы не ограничиваем. И суть, если говорить про деньги, то это 35 % от продажи.
Игорь А.: Нам не важно, вы ИП, самозанятый, любой может участвовать, эксперт в этом во всем. И, соответственно, когда попадает клиент в платформу, которую мы делаем, есть там и экспертная часть.
Игорь А.: То есть быть экспертом на платформе – это одно, мы сейчас этого особо глубоко не касаемся, но это тоже возможность есть. И быть партнером – это разные роли. То есть можно быть и то,
Игорь А.: и то, одно другому не противоречит. То есть у нас после профориентации собирается это все в профиль, который раскладывает, скажем так, все по полочкам. И дальше мы вот те пакеты, которые
Игорь А.: к вам приходят уже от Максима, например, клиенты на сессии, вот это все собираться будет все на платформе. То есть мы прям активно развиваем весь этот продукт, и первый шаг это профориентация.
Игорь А.: Вот, поэтому первое, что хотелось бы предложить, это вот поучаствовать в таком пилоте, когда мы запустим сам проект профориентации. То есть зарегистрироваться, попробовать, может быть,
Игорь А.: кому -то отправить ссылку. То есть в тот момент, когда это будет, например, кому -то из ваших клиентов актуально. Мы не хотим сейчас выходить в широкий массовый рынок и всем это предлагать.
Игорь А.: Мы хотим сейчас это опробовать на экспертах, с которыми мы взаимодействуем, которые нам дадут прямую честную обратную связь. Например, здесь плохо, здесь хорошо, здесь вот там еще как
Игорь А.: -то. докрутить этот продукт и потом уже только идти в такой широкий сегмент.
Игорь А.: Поэтому если у вас есть как раз таки, как вы говорите, стопор всем не рекомендовать, не впаривать, мы тоже не хотим, чтобы было такое у наших экспертов, а чтобы было такое вот, вот
Игорь А.: этому человеку надо, порекомендую, вот этой семье надо, здесь порекомендую. И тогда, чтобы это была не просто рекомендация, вы понимали, что вы даете пользу, и вы понимали, что вы от
Игорь А.: этого тоже получаете комиссию. И вы сами чувствовали, вы же общаетесь с семьями, мы не знаем, например, кто -то готов максимум 20, ему будет дорого, а кто -то готов 40 тысяч. И вот
Игорь А.: тоже, если там сравнивать, ну, условно говоря, в какой -то вакууме системе, почему, например, там два эксперта порекомендовали одной семье, у одной 50, цена у другой 35, здесь у нас
Игорь А.: будет следующая система, что при желании эксперт может пройти вот обучение по этой профориентации, по нашей, как ее проводить, и в пакет будет включаться его консультация. То есть у
Игорь А.: вас есть доверие, например, с семьей, у вас есть понимание, что этот продукт нужен, и вы понимаете, в принципе, какой путь дальше пойдет клиент с агентством.
Игорь А.: И с учетом этого, то есть вы можете ставить, условно говоря, свою цену и говорить о том, что в нее входит еще моя консультация по результатам данного прохождения. Потому что там отчет
Игорь А.: есть, там сейчас будет Максим проводить все эти консультации, чтобы обратную связь взять, чтобы мы этот продукт доточили. Но при этом обучение мы тоже готовим. И вот хотелось бы, может
Игорь А.: быть, от вас тоже какую -то обратную связь, интересно -неинтересно, и может мысли, они могут быть, могут не быть. И если окей, то когда будет готова, например, платформа, то я бы вам
Игорь А.: ссылку прислал, и еще раз бы мы прошлись, я бы вам все показал.
Ирина Т.: Да, Игорь, мыслей у меня много на эту тему. Смотрите, первых, конечно, да, давайте будем делать. Действительно, семьи, в которых подросли дети, которых я бывает уже по несколько лет
Ирина Т.: знаю, бывает, кто приходит именно с этой задачей, по профориентации, но они такие обычно жидкие достаточно, они не понятны, чего они хотят сами, и готовы ли они что -то купить. А вот
Ирина Т.: те дети, которые доросли уже, там им было по 16, стало по 17, по 18, кого -то с 12 знаю. Да, наверное, если продукт не будет весть по 150 -500, а что -то будет такое, какая -то программа,
Ирина Т.: которая 20 -50, наверное, ну есть люди, которые и больше готовы, но их меньше, чем те, которые нуждаются в помощи, но они способны в районе полтинника что -то внести за эту всю историю.
Ирина Т.: это первый момент здесь я могу да действительно я сейчас так подумала да действительно наверное кому -то могу рекомендовать но у меня большой вопросик входному тесту вашему кто его
Ирина Т.: адаптировал что это за т .п. потому что то что я читаю мне присылают ту ориентацию до которую присылают и я соотношусь с вашими же клиентами, с детьми,
Ирина Т.: она не соответствует в моей картине мира, реальности, то есть я вижу ребенка иначе. И это часто. Вот по Диане, например, мне не нравится вообще результат. Потому что то, что Диана выдает
Ирина Т.: в личном общении, оно вообще говорит не за те, ну как сказать, и критерии -то какие -то для меня странные, вот это вот то, что там описано. Мне прям не нравится он, откровенно, я же
Ирина Т.: уже не первый год с ним. И детей, наверное, шесть я прочитала уже, и нигде нет у меня согласия по нему. Кто это делал, почему вы именно ее взяли за основу?
Игорь А.: Ну, смотрите, я могу рассказать методологию, почему мы взяли за основу. Опять же, это делал не я, сразу скажу, но я как человек, присоединившийся к команде, я прошел и через профориентацию,
Игорь А.: у меня на старшей дочке очень все совпало, прям вплоть до того, что совпало до того направления, куда она хочет. А помладше там были вопросы, но она еще и маленькая, ей 12 лет пока.
Игорь А.: Игорь,
Ирина Т.: все -таки скажите мне, кто, какой профессии человек это делал? Кто это делал? Кто это был? Ну, это Максим. Это педагог был, это психотерапевт был, это Максим делал? Ну,
Игорь А.: понятное дело, что он привлекает экспертов. Я до конца методологию, кто конкретно делал, вам сейчас не могу сказать. Но я точно знаю, что Максим
Ирина Т.: в этом участвует. Ну, потому что надо обязательно понимать, в чем дело. Вот с какой колокольни. Вот если посади педагога, он тебе одно сделает. Посади там какого -нибудь психиатра,
Ирина Т.: он тебе другое сделает. Психотерапевт ты третья, а, не знаю, маркетолог четвертая. Но как бы вот то, что я смотрю, там надо корректировать совершенно точно. А можете рассказать
Игорь А.: немножко? Ну, это же полезная обратная связь. Вот и с вами, как с экспертом. Если мы
Ирина Т.: с вами сядем, возьмем прямо вот тест Дианин, например, или кто там перед этим, Марк у меня был, еще кто -то. Вот если мы прям возьмем, и
Игорь А.: я по конкретному
Ирина Т.: ребенку вам нестыковки могу показать, где что не стыкуется. То есть, ну, я полагаю, что, допустим, у меня было там 5 ваших детей, если бы мы взяли 50 детей, может быть, у 40 бы совпало,
Ирина Т.: у 10 нет, но мне сама вот это вот, знаете,
Ирина Т.: надо открыть, короче, его, на самом деле, чтобы нам поговорить об этом, не уверен, что сегодня. Надо просто открыть, и я покажу в табличке, где и что меня смущает очень. А мы можем
Ирина Т.: запланировать, и даже, может, в формате платной консультации? Там противоречия
Игорь А.: есть.
Игорь А.: Ну, можно и так, конечно, это будет еще приятнее. Там
Ирина Т.: есть, на мой взгляд, противоречия. И их нужно устранить. Не то, что все, давайте, уберем, значит, выкинем программу, но я бы эти противоречия устранила. Потому что люди, они тоже их
Ирина Т.: могут видеть, на самом деле. Ну и плюс, зачем нам, зачем нам с вами, ребенку не ту профориентацию дать. Вот я смотрю, например, у Дианы очень... Прям вот то, что по ее эмотивности тест
Ирина Т.: читал, ну, тест просто идиот, извините, потому что у Дианы, у нее эмотивный психотип, совершенно точно. То, что она боится всего, да, то, что она там... Ну, это травмы, да, определенные,
Ирина Т.: травмы развития, потому что очень отец такой, давлеющий, да, вот это все. Но то, что там про ее какие -то вот качества личные, да, она считала, все нормально, но эмотивность там высочайшая.
Ирина Т.: В этом санне в конце идет, что она, значит, ну, условно, там не то, что по головам идти, да, я не помню, сам вот, какими словами это было сказано, она может включить и действовать,
Ирина Т.: ничего она включить не может. Она вся, как вот эта, она как -то, как -то там, за дверюшкой оказывается, она очень немаловная, именно из этого она страдает. и это ей будет бедить, если
Ирина Т.: ее не научить своему большому количеству эмоций. Она не сможет управлять бизнесом, наоборот, вот то, что ей рекомендовано. Как она будет управлять, если она, ну, с утром не ходит в
Ирина Т.: положение каждого? То есть там надо вот и психологическая работа, вот он будет участвовать в том, чтобы ее адаптировать, конечно, все. Есть генеральная линия, которая, ну,
Ирина Т.: там было родительского теста какое -то, ну, как бы родительского мнения, какое -то количество. Игорь, вы куда -то пропали. Да, у меня что -то со связью. То есть я не понимаю, как он
Ирина Т.: с ее ответов. Возможно, она давала желаемые для
Игорь А.: папы ответы. Возможно.
Ирина Т.: Вот. Но, в общем, это не только по Диане. Если бы это было только по Диане, я помню, что с Марком я тоже, у меня прям такой диссонанс был. Потому что ребенок совсем другой. Не то выдало.
Ирина Т.: И я стала смотреть выше. То есть я стала смотреть на критерии. Думаю, как -то они странно не вяжутся между собой. Надо нам прям систи покопать. То есть если это не какой -то там ученый
Ирина Т.: эксперт был, который создал, или какая -нибудь там американская супер -купер -система, которая все, все против американской системы супер -купер -потерная. Но если это создавал какой
Ирина Т.: -то живой человек со своей картиной мира, то мы можем это скорректировать, добавить туда мою картину мира. Ну, отлично. Я обговорю с Максимом сегодня, у нас как раз будет
Игорь А.: созвон, да, и я передам. Это же классно, вот если бы сейчас с вами не пообщались, это вот как раз про улучшение продукта. Но я бы и не знал, например. Да, поэтому я предлагаю так, что
Игорь А.: эту информацию обязательно передам. Да, потому что я сайт создавал, чтобы Максиму
Ирина Т.: выкатило бы, что мне твои системы не нравятся, да?
Ирина Т.: Что со связи с вами не очень. Секундочку, я переключу на другой интернет, прошу прощения. Непременно говори. Я вас слышу, но у меня, да,
Игорь А.: действительно что -то отваливается, бывает сегодня.
Ирина Т.: Да, пожалуйста. Переключусь.
Игорь А.: Могу пропасть буквально секунд на 10 -20.
Говорящий 3: Так.
Игорь А.: Я снова здесь.
Ирина Т.: Вот. Ну, в общем, к чему я? К тому, чтобы не отрицать это все, а улучшить тоже, да? Я думаю, задача такая, как у вас. И если это действительно с Максимом, да, завязанная история, то
Ирина Т.: мы все -нибудь друг друга услышим. Но там надо будет корректировать никак. Мы не совсем реальную картинку получаем, по -моему.
Ирина Т.: Ну, насколько
Игорь А.: я знаю, там сейчас, да, переделывается тоже этот отчет. вот добавляется какой -то информационный слой я в сам продукт глубоко не лезу я знаю методологию я проходил его на себе вот но
Игорь А.: это классно если есть у вас и желание вы понимаете то есть как с одной стороны кому принести пользу до продать этот продукт и с другой стороны как его улучшить Поэтому информацию передам,
Игорь А.: все принял к сведению.
Игорь А.: Может быть, вы еще что -то не сказали, что хотели сказать, но у вас есть.
Игорь А.: Так, что
Ирина Т.: я еще хотела сказать? Что еще хотела сказать?
Ирина Т.: Как будет... Вот смотрите, допустим, я завожу клиент, который мне кажется, им будет это полезно. Соответственно, ему там агентство может предлагать репетиторов дальше, какую -то дальше
Ирина Т.: стратегию, да, там, ты, не знаю, вплоть до отправки учебного заведения, да. А у меня, получается, да, те эксперты, которые, не знаю, репетитор завел своего человека на платформу, и
Ирина Т.: ребенку требуется и родителям психологическая консультация, то есть я тоже как будто бы включаюсь в пакет других клиентов, да? Я правильно понимаю? Да, конечно.
Игорь А.: У нас, получается, платформа будет содержать слой, первый клиентский слой, второй слой экспертный слой и третий слой это партнерский слой. И одно другому не противоречит. То есть вы
Игорь А.: в ролях можете переключаться, вы сами можете быть, условно говоря, клиентом и экспертом и партнером. При этом, если эксперт, мы эту систему пока продумываем, но я думаю, что она будет
Игорь А.: выглядеть следующим образом, что эксперт, например, может в партнерскую сеть, чтобы его как бы рекомендовали и привлекали к большему количеству занятий. Как, например, сейчас есть на
Игорь А.: профиру купить отклики, то у нас будет немножко другая система. Мы хотим, чтобы эксперт, например, 10 -20 % от чека, который он выставляет, отдавал в партнерскую сеть. То есть, например,
Игорь А.: чтобы партнеры, как раз -таки такие же эксперты, рекомендовали, и пакет, который формируется, например, вы понимаете, вот есть ребенок, вот пришел пакет, и здесь там будет, вы привлекли
Игорь А.: на профориентацию, и вы будете видеть всю эту обратную связь, вы будете видеть весь этот профиль ребенка, не в таком виде отчета, он будет уже разложен по полочкам профиля самого ребенка.
Игорь А.: Там догрузил оценки, профиль увидели, догрузил еще какую -то информацию, то есть будет постоянно пополняемый профиль. То есть мы уже сейчас тестируем на текущих некоторых клиентах эту
Игорь А.: всю систему внутреннюю. И то же самое касаемо экспертов. То есть профориентацию прошли, есть пакет, который нужно с психологом, с математиком, с английским языком. И вы понимаете, ага,
Игорь А.: я могу привлечь вот этого эксперта английского языка, он проведет там 10 занятий или там 20 занятий, ну сколько требуется. И за то, что, например, вы привели клиента, вы получили от
Игорь А.: этого там 35%, если
Ирина Т.: привели,
Игорь А.: например, и порекомендовали какого -то эксперта, он ставит, например, в системе там 10 -20 % какую -то ставку. И это все тоже распределяется в партнерскую сеть, соответственно, вам,
Игорь А.: как человеку, который привел и порекомендовал этого эксперта, и там платформа немного забирает себе. То есть таким образом и комьюнити сообщества формируются, и польза формируется,
Игорь А.: и еще и в материальном виде, в виде денег. бонус не просто с первого касания с профориентации 100%, но и там небольшой заработок от того, как клиент идет внутри системы, потому что
Игорь А.: клиенту у нас потом, он и второй раз профориентацию проходит, там и третий может раз пройти,
Ирина Т.: пока вот обучается и меняется. То есть мы хотим, получается, партнера который привлекает к нам клиентов условно говоря давать
Игорь А.: доход на всем этапе жизни клиента внутри системы но пока начинаем вот именно с профориентации потому что этот продукт
Ирина Т.: мы уже оцифровали
Игорь А.: и он уже готовый внутри на платформе есть если на платформе ресурс для хранения, например, полезных видео
Ирина Т.: или нет? Все это есть, все это вот чего там, например, нет, то мы дорабатываем. Сейчас мы уже тестируем видеозвонки и они
Игорь А.: внутри остаются, системы с транскрибацией, с самим видео и так далее. Если вы сейчас говорите про какой -то обучающий курс загрузить, мы это тоже можем сделать.
Игорь А.: То есть не скачиваемый
Ирина Т.: для клиента, да, то есть для просмотра, ну как, типа где курсы? ЛМС, да, конечно. Есть. Так, еще вопрос. Вот оценки, понятно, догружаются, там, или еще какие -то отчеты. По психотерапии
Ирина Т.: же мы не можем туда догрузить отчеты, потому что там виден слишком большому количеству людей. Понимаете, статистки, да, психотерапии? Да, конечно.
Ирина Т.: Смотрите, мы... То есть я не буду этого делать, потому что этого нельзя делать. Да, мы вот эти юридические моменты тоже прорабатываем со своей стороны. Мы понимаем, есть законодательства
Ирина Т.: в разных странах, и вот этот момент в
Игорь А.: работе, то есть это мы понимаем.
Игорь А.: Еще
Игорь А.: хотел спросить,
Игорь А.: для родителей это отличный кубинет, как жизнь в день, да, ребенке? Да, конечно, к родителю, то есть родитель является, если 18 лет нет пользователю, то родитель является входной точкой,
Игорь А.: он в семью добавляет, например, второго родителя и детей, и каждый из родителей может переключиться в кабинет ребенка и посмотреть те данные, которые там ребенок открывает.
Игорь А.: И ребенке в курсе, да, то есть это для него прозрачная система, он тоже заходит туда, он может смотреть, что ему там наставили, да? Да, конечно, у него формируется этот профиль, который
Игорь А.: раскладывает
Ирина Т.: всю эту информацию, которую как раз -таки ребенок либо родитель подгружает, ну и плюс наши цифровые продукты, которые он проходит, они оцифровываются и вовнутрь подгружаются.
Ирина Т.: Вот смотрите, если, например,
Игорь А.: я думаю,
Ирина Т.: что надо новые какие -то записать продукты, на самом деле, уже
Игорь А.: именно под тот контингент, который от вас идет, более направленный по подросткам,
Ирина Т.: допустим, какие -то видео, курсом не буду, именно точечные, посмотреть, например, по созданию безопасного пространства в отношениях или по наполнению ребенка контактом близости, по
Ирина Т.: выстраиванию границ, там эти общения, еще что -то, да? То есть родители, как это будет продаваться, скажем так? То есть это будет просто дополнительно посмотрите или это тоже какую
Ирина Т.: -то стоимость на это ставить? Мы можем ставить на это стоимость. У нас уже готов функционал маркетплейса цифровых продуктов. Вопросы, опять же, наполнения. Вы, например, можете одним
Ирина Т.: из первых наполнить. У нас есть цифровой продукт как профориентация, как точка входа. Вы можете своими продуктами наполнить. У нас еще есть одна сущность, которую я не сказал, но она
Ирина Т.: по факту есть. это как агентство то есть можно создать внутри свое агентство
Игорь А.: своих экспертов вовнутрь
Ирина Т.: пригласить свои цифровые продукты выложить но это уже как бы сейчас выходим мы за рамки я вам в целом рассказываю про уже про платформу потому что как бы . в которую я зашел это через
Ирина Т.: партнерскую программу на самом деле мы прям целую экосистему строим хорошо
Игорь А.: получается дальше что у нас нет
Игорь А.: поговорить по поводу самого тестирования а с тем я думаю что с максимом проговорю этот момент и напишу вам обратную связь когда с кем у
Ирина Т.: вас может быть тоже было дело говорить уже на эту тему, но до каких -то изменений у нас не дошло, потому что он верит в то, что он сделал. Мы здесь с ним немножко разошлись.
Ирина Т.: Он даже знает, кстати говоря, на чем я основалась, на своей профориентации людей,
Игорь А.: особенно психотипа
Ирина Т.: людей, и там что -то по -другому. у меня. Ну, не знаю, короче, надо попробовать поговорить, на самом деле, может мы действительно просто какие -то
Ирина Т.: параметры другие внесем, а что -то, может быть, уберем. Ну, если он, конечно, это пойдет. Ладно, если надо поговорить, нет, нет, соответственно, будет такая, просто она мне не очень,
Ирина Т.: не вызывает согласия вот так вот, я когда начинаю с ребенком
Игорь А.: работать, читаю цель, во -первых, он очень утомительный, он огромный, ну, отчет, и там очень часто повторения идет. Вот дуб орехали мочал, одно и то же. Вроде уже все ясно, мы еще раз
Игорь А.: повторим, что вот это.
Ирина Т.: Как родители читают, мне кажется, они очень устают тоже, он очень большой. Ну, я читал, понятное дело, что какие -то, я как родитель, я тоже начал с того, что
Игорь А.: прошел для детей, для своих, где -то я пролистывал, где -то я прям читал и такой, о, вот это
Ирина Т.: точно. Ну, то есть я как бы возвращался несколько раз к этому отчету. Ну, жена у меня более подробно это все читала, я так больше где -то между строк, где -то прям... Надо мне прогнать
Ирина Т.: по своим, надо мне этот тест на своих прогнать, который уже, ну, старшая у меня определена, и она на своем месте в близне находится, очевидно, и вот посмотреть, как на ней сработает.
Игорь А.: Мы можем
Ирина Т.: дать вам... Это четко проверить можно, да, сработало, сработало а по тынул как раз можно попробовать
Игорь А.: смогу ли я эту информацию с помощью тебе взять чтобы его понять потому что я понимаю точно а
Ирина Т.: вот приложите вы куда еще пока не совсем не короче на своих попробовать и на клиентах я могу попробовать потому что а не сетях я Я прям давно Кинкосею уже знаю, потому что недавно
Игорь А.: работает. И тоже посмотреть, как она сработает. Именно в качестве соответствия такого, чтобы мне успокоиться. Может, она действительно соответствует, а я просто по этим новым детствам
Игорь А.: вижу как -то по другим. Мы же психологический слой не накладываем. Мы разбираем действительно в этом тесте навыки и предрасположенности.
Игорь А.: Навыки – это навыки. А предрасположенность,
Ирина Т.: она изначально, она не может быть не психологическая, а психологические как раз критерии. Ну хорошо, давайте тогда так, я позову на созвон Максима, который в методологии намного лучше
Ирина Т.: меня
Игорь А.: разбирается.
Ирина Т.: Ладно, просто короче Максиму так, чтобы мне не хочется с него в противостояние здесь вступать, да, потому что он это создавал, он молодец, он классный, я вообще
Игорь А.: очень ему верю, заверяю, уважаю все
Ирина Т.: такое. Не
Игорь А.: для того, чтобы обесценить, а для того, чтобы доработать как -то.
Ирина Т.: Может быть, здесь становится чуть неспокойно, но самое главное, чтобы у нас это выходило в более качественное продукт, чтобы мы не
Игорь А.: наморочили голову детям
Ирина Т.: и не выпекли по направлению, которое на самом деле будет за них обучить. Это правильно, это хорошо, я прям за. Поэтому будем докручивать тогда
Игорь А.: продукт. Вот, я все передам и с вами свяжусь по поводу времени, когда будет удобно.
Ирина Т.: Да, давайте. Значит, получается, вот
Игорь А.: этот созвон, он имеет смысл. И дальше что? Дальше вы мне зададите ссылку
Ирина Т.: на платформу, чтобы я зашла посмотрела, что там есть, да? Да, когда она будет готова, я думаю, что мы с вами
Игорь А.: там еще минут на 15 -20 созвонимся. Я вам покажу, где что, как куда клацать, как формировать эти свои офферы, то есть предложение, как этот лендинг дальше делается. Вот, это на этой
Игорь А.: неделе будет. То есть мы уже прям на выходных немножко не доделали ее. Сейчас, я не знаю, к середине недели, наверное, оттестируем все и уже будем выкатывать для
Ирина Т.: всех. А экспертные, кто там народов, народов вообще, братья
Говорящий 3: репетиторов и все остальное, да, именно не продающих, а экспертных?
Говорящий 3: Не понял вопрос.
Говорящий 3: Людей, которые занимаются с детьми, например. Их сколько, 10, 100, какого масштаба вообще эта история? В нашей системе? Да. Ну, она сейчас в десятках измеряется. Ну, а знака же 10 или
Говорящий 3: 80? То есть это там 20 человек. Я просто пытаюсь понять, во что я захожу. Сейчас больше 50.
Говорящий 3: Ого, понятно, поняла. И это что у нас получается? Вот еще раз сказать, а психологов там какое количество? Я не буду разглашать такую информацию, потому что не знаю конкретно сколько
Говорящий 3: кого.
Говорящий 3: На платформе же это видно будет? На платформе, да, это видно будет.
Говорящий 3: Ну, да,
Говорящий 3: хорошо. Да, благодарю, Ирина, тогда за звонок. В общем, пообщаюсь с Максимом и скажу, когда можем с вами тоже созвониться.
Говорящий 3: Если будет готово там сегодня, я сегодня скину, ну так где -то к среде давайте вот так готовиться, так чтобы не спеша, точно где -то вот плюс -минус платформу вам скину, и там уже тоже
Говорящий 3: договоримся по платформе на созвон.
Говорящий 3: Хорошо, спасибо, Игорь. Да, и вам спасибо.